okay hi everyone this is my fourth live
stream of today
um
but
energy persists
um we are talking about chemistry
functionality for version 13 of wolfram
language
and
the first function we are supposed to
look at is what
findings is this an agenda for
oh is this i see defined isomers is up
there
see by the way brady uh
a practical point would be really good
if that could be a link that actually
pulls up this isn't my this isn't my
agenda but i know it's not your agenda i
actually i actually tried that uh i made
a link in docutools and then copied it
back out into the other notebook but
because of the style sheet it didn't go
to the docutools version it tried to
open up the
documentation center
oh you can use the dot i can
okay
so if there's a way to do that i'll
figure it out yeah
there is i'll tell you
and you should tell every other person
who's setting up design review meetings
as well
okay
okay find isomores
beautiful
so for example if i say
these are the chemical isomers right not
the nuclear ones
correct
so you'll want to wrap that in molecule
um
that's not an adequate result
correct why do i need to wrap it a
molecule oh i guess you don't
um but apparently that i haven't tested
that before and i check it to see if
it's a name before i check it to see if
it's a smiles and so i need to
fix that
you shouldn't see that error is what i
mean to say
what's that about
it should work with a list of molecules
what should it do how should they be
represented
well i was just thinking it makes a list
of plots
but most plot functions
okay
i mean it would be nice if that um
well that's lovely what are those
uh so that represents stereochemistry
you're seeing uh the the particular
carbon that you're looking at is going
back into the page
okay so now let's say i want the graphs
here how would i get those
so either do molecule graph on them or i
believe that charles had
was
working to make graph more omnivorous
i think this is the word i heard them i
use
well actually i'm going to just try
doing this so that works
psy why doesn't that work i mean it
doesn't have any good reason not to work
that is a reasonable
suggestion
right okay so and you mentioned the uh
this and i haven't done it yet that the
molecule graph should construct a
molecule or a graph with the vertex
coordinates
yes um
but what occurred to me the r and i
didn't think of this until after the
meeting the reason it doesn't do that is
because that's
that can take a non-zero amount of time
and sometimes you want the graph
you don't want to look at it you just
want to do computation and actually i
mean it takes
it takes me longer to to lay out a
molecule in 2d than it even than it does
a graph generally because there's more
things to consider
um
and so i think it's useful i think it's
useful by default now
the question of whether
um
well at least molecule graph needs some
kind of option or something
right so it could take the vertex
coordinates option and they could by
default
let's see so
well vertex coordinates are automatic
might
what was that supposed to mean i mean
that or inherited or something
i'm not convinced here how long does it
really take
and it could take a long time for some
complicated protein-like molecule or
something for a large molecule it can
take it could take uh tens of
milliseconds
usually
give me a big molecule
hemoglobin do we have that
uh
not in a good way to uh type i usually
make a biosequence if i want to uh
um
make a big molecule because that's the
convenience
that's pretty cool but now why did it
even oh wow
so that's just graph laying it out there
wow
that's neat
that's a good example by the way please
send that to me for my examples
collection
okay
um
okay so michael what do you think yeah
with respect to whether this should
happen by the i i'm i'm lean i'm
agreeing with you that happening by
default doesn't seem to make sense
we just need a way i don't know what
what people would most often do
i would like to see the the molecule
plot coordinates on the graphs that
makes the most sense to me you can
relate directly to the chemistry at that
point but then we should have an option
like we have even for down values yeah
right sort of or not it might be
non-trivial amount of time for some
applications
so then then the thing to do would be
in molecule graph give a vertex
coordinates option
[Music]
automatic is is uh molecule coordinates
and then
the string
graph i don't think that's the right way
to do it because i think we've already
got vertex coordinates what are the
other settings right now for vertex
coordinates
so they
can usually be a list of the strings
what how could this not be found
why is vertex coordinates not found your
front end seems to be disconnected from
your uh documentation like that's my
guess
just because
i was going to say that i think the
closest analog i can think of is what to
do what mesh
mesh connectivity graph does by default
it can inhabit the coordinates in a mesh
but you can also set the vertice
coordinates to just use a generic layout
how does it how does it do that
i forgot what charles did for that
particular part but the there's a way by
default it inhabits
coordinates from the mesh
came from
annotation rules inherited okay so
we should probably find out how it does
this
um but i kind of think
i i'm kind of thinking that automatic
means the usual vertex coordinates are
automatic
and that vertex coordinates arrow
inherited should pull in the one from
the molecule
so it makes sense
and that the default should be inherited
and that it's only for the more advanced
users who want to make things run
quickly that they use automatic
yeah i can do that
okay
and we should find out the answer to
this mesh connectivity graph question
okay lovely
so one question um about find isomers
that i didn't i didn't put uh anything
in the documentation but i wonder
how one might document this fact that uh
if you have a function that is going to
return
10 000 molecules
and you do not end it with a semicolon
it uh
can be very disruptive it because
through reasons uh i'm not
quite sure
it's not going to show you all of it
because you have an output limiter but
it's still going to lay them all out
it's still going to form that's a bug
well i think it's just the way that
well
that may be true
so
nothing to document just fix the book
i mean i understand what's generating
all of them well no i mean so in general
if you
return
to the front end a list of anything
right the way i understand it
is the it still calls and formats
everything and then it decides to do
short and to a light thing what are you
talking about
is slightly different the reason is that
the output limit
for some things that are
formatted is still pretty high relative
like if it would be a pure string it
would be no problem to show it but if
it's something that needs sufficient
amount of formatting it can still be a
lot of work
just explain to me the case we're
talking about i mean if i say find
isomers
of
what's that
c10h18 is enough
why
okay i
don't know why that's happening
okay
right and so then at this point um okay
well this is for the front-end team it's
not for you it's not for us
okay
that's right i mean you've already
you've computed the structures right
correct okay so is it a transmission
problem how big are the structures
there themselves aren't that big it's
it's exactly the problem that are
relatively small
right so the structures themselves are
much smaller than their boxes i guess or
i'm not so i'll contact the frontiers
okay something is wrong here it's not
yeah
okay so you're telling me that if i were
to do
and now i'm about to find out if you
cash
are you cashing
no
well you should be shouldn't you
why not
why not cash
let's see so um
so that's always a question right so if
if you c if you're always caching and
someone is doing something in a loop
then that then they they can point to
that and say that's evidence of a memory
leak right
um that's that's a that's a sub issue
i don't think that's an issue i mean i
would
i don't know whether this is the right
thing to cash
anybody else got an opinion about that
i would say no
output can be large i'll contact uh l
kernel and see if that uh or
yeah that's my thought is that the
output can be quite large
okay
all right
especially for the computed ones
potentially
yes
do we really get to see cayley's end of
the n minus three here
how would you
otherwise if i just say
what happens if i say
here
what would happen if i just say c10
does it hydrogenate automatically
no so it should find nothing and in this
case i
there's a bug where it's going to return
unevaluated so
no so i guess
pubchem has some entries like that
okay
that first one looks like something
maybe from meijin
because it will give you
the the ring with all double bonds
uh where the scale types of carbon
you've ever seen
so i just want to these java errors that
you're seeing i'll need to contact roger
so the paclet uninstall command up at
the very top seems to have not removed
that
uh packet from last time what is that
creature
hey
it's like a baby chick
what
this looks like a baby chick looks like
michael michael bucketball
yes something like this
okay so how do i find out what it is
let's so uh
or not
so you could copy it and ask for the the
sub value pubchem compound id
and that'll give you an external
identifier with a that'll link out
so someone made an entry in that for
that uh
pubchem compound id
yes why isn't this also completing
there's something wrong with the
autocompleter here it should be this is
a literal case right it's a sub-value of
molecule it knows it's a sub-value i sh
i have not i will set those up
okay
so then the number is a hyperlink
most likely somebody made that um just
in a computer program and submitted it
they were able to come up with a name
for it but i i would guess that nobody
has made that
oh it
looks like a prismane
i don't think they make pushments that
small
oh somebody
okay
i'm just wondering if this is a real
thing or whether
okay who knows
generally it doesn't have to have
actually been uh synthesized to be no i
realized that
but okay i mean this looks like a very
weird object
i'm just kind of wondering why we have
it and also
boy there's some strange things here
okay
could this actually hang together
no very unlikely
and and not even the poly you know maybe
the polyacetylene the one you've got
highlighted selected yeah
well the polyacetylenes are commonly
used as conducting
black conducting plastic so that might
have a chance to be structurally seen
yeah and the last one i think there's a
nitrile variation of that instead of
acetylene to it would have uh
nitrile groups
c triple bond n sometimes called cyanide
as well yeah okay i've heard of that
um
why does okay my chemistry moment
cyanide doesn't cyanide bind the the ion
and the hemoglobin
yes
yes it binds the iron and hemoglobin if
it's a cyanide anion
you want it to a cyano group in an
organic molecule it's stable
generally
but otherwise
rips the iron out of the hemoglobin
it keeps oxygen it displaces oxygen and
it binds much more tightly than oxygen
does and that's why it's poison
association that a cyanide is sticking
to the eye or oxygen cannot stick to the
iron anymore
and we suffocate
right
okay
um
okay i mean but we're not horrified by
this result
in fact we are impressed by this result
is that a true statement yes
i'm kind of surprised that they're
actually in pub chem yes
the first two look horrifying
what the heck are these
i'm gonna go spelunking this what is
that what is that creature now i've just
learned it's full of acetylenes it's a
yeah it's a it's a cyclic polyacetylene
yes
can it be made it's really dubious right
because those uh they want to have a 180
degree bond angles like
well yeah i mean this is laying it out
with hexagonal geometry but uh that ring
is large enough
uh if if you made um
an icosagon i guess that's what it's
called uh a 20 gone
and measured the internal angles they
would be distorted from 180 degrees yes
but not greatly so
so yeah
and so in princeton you know something
like that could be stable enough to put
into a bottle
wow
okay one of these is the buckyball
presumably that one
i think the second one
so if i take that second one and i say
um
let's put it that's a molecule plot if i
say this
i'm obviously
some of which is an ion actually so it's
the first one i didn't notice the
negative charge
this is quite magnificent that we can do
all of this
i should really be calling to graph when
laying out uh
fullerenes no i mean i'm serious like
the uh
the uh
yeah well but that's the spring
electrical model is probably
i don't recall ever seeing graff lay out
a fullerene like that before uh
the spring electrical model is pretty
good for laying out uh goldberg
polyhedra in general so levine's
easy
well so it was my impression that graf
would try and do a planar embedding on
on a no
no way okay i mean it's a planar graph
so
what's yeah
it can be invented in the plane but it's
not the best way to look at it
no right i mean uh the automatic methods
i have in the molecule package for uh
laying out these fluorines it just
it gives up and goes for the the planar
embedding
so you're saying here
there's a bug in this there's a bug here
obviously there's a bug there
wow
this is very buggy please i will
so you are ending up with that kind of
embedding is that true
yes
okay
what are these guys i mean are these
anything real or are they just sort of
somebody's drawing what's that thing is
that carbons
yeah it is yes yeah a four membered ring
but you can't make that can you
format yeah cyclobutane yeah
stable
it's got a lot of ring strain
right if you want to make explosives you
like those uh small rings
okay well i'm going to go spelunky i
want to find out what graphs you can
make out of carbon
that seems like a good
challenge for molecular computing and so
on
is
um okay okay let me stop getting
distracted here okay let's get back to
business
what was the next thing here reaction
balanced queue
so find isomers we're done with yeah
yeah
what's
form uh
so what do you what do you when it can
be returned in a particular type why
don't you say graph why don't you have a
graph as one of those as well why not
yeah
i can do that okay
this is a nice function
i think it's a very useful function
um at least for me even if nobody
because i don't make actual chemicals at
least
yet so we um
we're working we on another function
that uh
will generate iso i guess we would call
it generate isomers um
but there you really get into a
combinatorial explosion
right that's for a different
different meaning
i see so there
i mean in this case if it isn't in
pubchem it doesn't exist so if i take
sort of find isomers
of um
you know just a random thing like i say
find isomers oops
oops that's not what i wanted i said
find isomers of c100
right and that's going to return an
empty list the fact that it's returning
unevaluated is a bug
okay
something went wrong with my selection
here
okay so you're saying if i i mean i'm
just out of my curiosity
wow
whatever
right so someone someone decided to kind
of populate all the polyacetylenes that
they could and submit them is what it
looks like
yeah it's that guy
i i think we're gonna find if we look
far enough we're gonna find some
obscenity or something draw another
molecule in pubchem
perhaps
great
okay
uh all right let's see we we're looking
at chemical reaction
which right now
is very it's going to be very expensive
experimental for this
first release um chemical reaction is
what represents an actual instant an
actual reaction with
not uh not a pattern no templates
right
so an example would be
okay so this one here
why is it taking time to grind what's it
doing
what was it doing when it
probably uh converting each of those
entities into molecules
i see
why is that slow
why is that slow
i'm i'm not sure it should not be
so but that returns a common reaction
but what happens if i want to get it in
this form of a
of a yeah what happens if i want to get
it in this form
so i don't have a sub value to return uh
that if you if you ask it for its
reactant counts and its product counts
you can get either side of that and we
get that the whole thing though it seems
okay so what would we what's a should we
rules reaction rule
yeah yeah that makes sense
yeah
um
okay
and otherwise okay so balanced
reaction
balanced cue
by the way i notice in that autocomplete
do you guys have any involvement with
the reaction pde stuff
i think that's oliver's
it is all of us yeah
no i mean so i've looked over a couple
of examples like some really interesting
ones we wrote about uh with catalytic
converters and surfaces i don't know if
that's related to it at all yeah well
probably but i mean my question is
is this
um
i would love to event to make this into
something that he can
use
right but i just want to make sure that
it's consistent
reaction coefficient blah
worth just having a little look
whether it makes sense
okay let's let's look at template
reaction which is the main thing you
want to talk about right
oh molecule free q what the heck's that
uh it's when i was just slipping in here
if we have molecule match q and we have
molecule contains q
um it's just a convenience function
that's essentially equivalent to
not the negation of molecule contains q
so if i want to find out does this
contain a sulfur i just say molecule
free q blah comma s is that correct yes
so for example i could take this
molecule here
uh
uh
well you just you did contains cue
oh
it doesn't contain a sulfur
so so
so but it's oh
so sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
too many live streams
yeah all right the um okay
now my question is about hydrogens
okay so if i say molecule
cc
right that implicitly has hydrogens
and now i say molecule free q
okay right and so we
we use uh hydrogen suppressed graphs
when appropriate underneath the hood but
we've we try to make that into an
implementation detail
okay
why does that happen
let's see um
so what you should do i believe it
should work
if you gave include hydrogens goes to
explicit only as the option to molecule
free q
but essentially i try the
include hydrogens as an option to
molecule i try not to to use or
advertise because our users found find
it confusing that the whether having to
worry about whether the molecule has
implicit or explicit hydrogens so it
essentially
they're always there if you ask for them
and if there are cases where we can do
things more efficiently without them
then i'll remove them
i see so this isn't
what i made was a molecule even with
include hydrogens to false
really
so if i do so but you're saying what is
the case that you're saying here
so molecule free q of my
molecule well what happens if i say
explicit
what is only
and so give that as an option not to
molecule but as an option of molecule
free q so you're saying if i say cc is a
smile string there's no way with any
include hydrogen's
you know
stuff
that i can
request
the thing without the hydrogens so if
you want
just two connected carbon atoms then the
way to do that is in a smile string is
to wrap them in hard brackets okay okay
fine so there's a smiley way to do it
um
and
yeah okay
fair enough
um this goes back to what we've talked
about on and off a lot about hydrogens
and whether or not a molecule
if it would normally have them to to
have them in the representation
uh as opposed you know and
as opposed to something syntactic that's
completely structural from language and
whether or not they're
there as what you've written in most
users most uses of molecule
expect the hydrogens to be there
uh
you know in in the representation
okay fair enough
all right reactions
okay we're just starting on reactions so
reactions are a complicated area i very
strongly believe that our whole
multi-computation story
of um
uh you know how we represent
essentially transformations
that take multiple inputs
and give multiple outputs is going to be
the same story as reactions
in other words
let's imagine that what we've got is a
list of expressions
whatever it is something like this
then what i'm imagining is that it's a
floating super expressions
and we will have transformations which
say things like
f of you know i don't know what f of
blank
comma
g of f of
a blank
comma g of of f of b blank or something
that whole thing goes to
g of f of f whatever it is
that that transformation
is basically the same kind of thing as
these chemical reaction transformations
although the chemical reaction case is
closer to the graph transformation case
do you agree disagree have a thought
about this
so it is definitely uh close to the to
the graph transformation like using kind
of it's basically like a
in in
so it is the your same your graph
rewrite rules
with and there's a convenient
language
used because because the graphs here you
know their vertex and edge
labeled and those labels matter so much
there's they've we've uh there's a
convenient syntax or people have adopted
a notation for these types of
transformations what do you mean
um so let's so there's so you can have
like just like you can have smiles you
can have reaction smiles reaction yeah
right where you have these numbered
atoms and things
right i will place uh one in the
chat here
i would have thought that that would um
okay so just imagine that should have
evaluated and worked and uh um
but essentially i mean what you have
there is you have um
on the you have the
the two angle brackets denoting the the
left and the right hand side of the
transformation and then you label the
atoms
with the the mapping number
and then you have uh shorthand for types
of bonds
and so in this case you have a double
bond being two double bonds being
converted into a
single bond
so this is a hydrogenation reaction
which means nothing to me but yeah if
that didn't evaluate then i i have fear
that the other examples won't as well
but
can i see an example over here or
right so try taking off the word
chemistry there i i wonder if maybe
you're the uh extra packlet that's
floating around yeah okay so that's the
issue
so what happens if i say molecule plot
of this
so uh you would do a chemistry reaction
plot
because i have not got that ready for
system
so hover over the atoms this is one of
the neater parts about it um
that is neat
although the the ends of that double
bond
aren't there two atoms there and do they
both go to the same place no that one is
an obscure case right
which one is it
see what i'm saying there are two atoms
at the end of that double bond but only
one atom on that you know single bond so
the so that uh so
let's see so there's no
double bond has just one carbon and it's
highlighting one carbon on each side oh
yeah yeah right okay you're right
it's not that great i i sometimes wonder
if for ethan for ethene
it wouldn't be better to to adopt uh
the all atom representation for the 2d
like we do with water
well molecule with ethylene would show
it with the hydrogens also
yeah
okay this is a reaction plot which is
has more religion
okay
that's pretty neat
boy
this is so similar to what we're doing
with other things it's so similar
right and
so whatever uh
so what we have for now essentially
follows the let's see so it's compatible
with the reaction
or let's see i think the technical term
for them is smirks
which so they came out with smiles and
then smarts and then now is smirks
although to be honest so uh
daylight is the company who who wrote
the standard for these types of uh line
notations
but uh
there is um let's see what am i saying
you know uh it's up to everyone else to
implement them and so the rules that
they specify for smirks
are not universally applied
um
but it's it's
right so it's not terribly standardized
but that is it's a
smirx is a way of writing a chemical
reaction as a transformation object
and so
we essentially have uh the longer form
of template reaction would be a list of
molecule patterns going to another list
of molecule patterns
and and also describing the the atom the
patterns with as atom patterns and and
bond patterns but with the caveat that
you
uh number the
uh the atoms
in some way
okay
um
okay let me see here
uh okay so what are we looking at here
we're
i mean
what does reaction apply okay so that's
that's basically a bunch of rules
so reaction apply takes the reaction as
the first argument and then a list of of
molecules as the second
and then spits back
a list of lists of products
why doesn't it take just one atom here
there's a there's a multiple atoms which
can occur
in the reaction this is a soup
where you can pick out any subset from
this it's like subset replace is that
correct
let's see so jason is that one of my
examples yes yeah okay so
it was just using the same reaction
and one of the same starting materials
but a
a different
choice of starting material from that
list
just to see what the different products
would be
one at a time
how do we get
all of the subsets here
or maybe it's overlaps there are true
oh come on how does one do this
[Music]
no
that's crazy
how do i
oh i can obviously use another version
or i can just go to the web
right so um
if i can uh you mentioned uh well so uh
while you're looking at this uh so you
mentioned like kind of treating the the
second argument so we have a reaction
applies taking the reaction and then a
list of molecules and the question of
whether to treat that as
a soup of molecules or
to treat that as a list
of ordered list which you then match
against the ordered list of reactants in
the molecule
um is something that we have thrown
around back and forth i understand
you've got exactly the same problems
we've got in this general
multicomputation area
so exact same set of problems
so it's yeah so we should solve them all
together rather than solving them
concretely
um
which is why we're not i'm not trying to
rush reaction apply and template
reaction in uh
out
in the next uh a little bit
i'm thinking about this by the way uh
volunteer on our live stream is asking
can you only number the significant
atoms
let's see so you um
if you don't number
an atom like let's see so yes so
you want to only include the significant
atoms and you only want to number them
if you have an atom on one side of the
other and it's not numbered then it's
not clear
what to do with it and so by default
uh it's disposed of but wait a minute so
are these supposed to be subgraph
transformations yes
yes
that's another whole eye rolling can of
worms
because sometimes you want that and
sometimes you want
right the whole molecule is consumed in
the reaction
right it only happens if it's the whole
molecule being consumed isn't that
right well let's see so the pattern
matches against uh part of the molecule
and then the whole molecule is
transformed like
you're saying i understand that i
understand that but there are some
patterns
which i would think you would want that
are only whole molecule transformations
right okay so then um
yeah that's kind of like including uh
start of string end of string on the
string pattern yeah that's a good
analogy yeah so we need something like
that a wrapper that says
guys
we are in the process of inventing
something which does this for general
pattern matching we should use that
technology yeah again what is the
non-smirky
form of this reaction
let's see so if you open up the
polymerization of amino acids they're
they're a little larger but
they're laid out in full form
laugh
we surely should have a more
programmatic version of end colon five
like and list n comma five or something
right so actually so um yeah that could
that could work uh what also works is
atom and
comma atom map number goes to five
but i got tired of typing that out as
much and so i
uh
defaulted to this but they both work but
the sub string the string
n comma five
does that work
no so so i thought you meant like adam
first argument and com list and comma
five yeah that's what i'm suggesting
yeah i it does not work but that is
that is uh preferable to me over uh
atom map number goes to
i mean it would translate to the to the
latter right jason
will
or or would you allow
the first element of an atom to be a
list of an atomic symbol and a mapping
number
so i think the latter right
that might lead to confusion where
people who are not doing reactions might
think that means some kind of isotope
number or something like that
sorry what which was this what if if you
said adam open bracket open list
uh quote c quote comma 13.
close list closed bracket now this is
the 13th atom somebody might think you
mean carbon 13.
instead it might be better to have
something like atom
again
let's find out what we're going to do
for other purposes but something like
this
yeah
i was thinking
the other day about this stuff along
with the multi-computation and and the
graph rewriting and then the graph
rewriting for the uh physics project
there you're writing your graphs you've
already got all the vertices labeled as
it were and you and the rewrite patterns
do as well
um and when i had trouble trouble i had
with that in the past to do it with for
chemistry was trying to say that a given
uh vertex was a carbon or an oxygen
there was no way i could make that
specification
and on the chemistry side we're just the
other way around we label everything
with the atomic symbols
and now all the vertices quote you know
they look the same and we have to add
number labels to them street addresses
to distinguish
and well there's an easy way in look
in the world of i mean it's not undoable
i mean like for example
in in physics project land
um a good example
a good if wacky example
is
we just got a self loop there to
represent a different
type of thing right that's a very pure
graph
type thing right you can imagine there's
nothing that says the rewrite rules
can't apply
around an annotation which in this case
is a very graph intrinsic annotation of
a self loop
okay yeah i in fact i'd use self-loops
to label some of the atoms because they
were special for what i was trying last
year
that worked to a degree
right but annotations i think would go a
very long way to let chemistry be
represented this way right well i think
that the general idea is
we're not going to use pure graphs we're
going to use something closer to
expressions and what we're going to have
is a big expression rewriting thing
you know the issue is there's this
trade-off because the graphs
yeah i mean the graphs connect things
expressions
have more structure
but it's always on a tree
and we just have to get the best of all
those pieces and that's why
when we next time we have one of these
multi-computation discussions it'd be
good if people didn't say nothing
because we we already know we've got
targets like the theorem proving stuff
like this molecule stuff we already know
we've got to unify those things
independent of all of the other stuff i
think we will not understand this
meeting that's why we didn't say
something oh well
that's the way i can imagine myself not
speaking up in a multi-computation
meeting though yeah
i yeah
i i i have tunnel vision i i can
i'm not sure that you're the right
person specifically for that that
meeting but okay so anything else we
should particularly try and figure out
with these reactions right now
i think the big thing is
okay so
what what you're figuring out here
is largely
graft rewriting is that true i mean in
other words the question of you know is
it endothermic is it exothermic that is
way out of band
or is that not way out of band is that
something you can compute given
uh
certain binding energies and molecules
and things
no that i mean so our ability to do that
uh rests at the moment with whatever's
uh whatever thermodynamic data can
handle and so it's in the realm of the
other uh of chemical reaction instead of
template reaction that kind of thing
but even there no that's something we
have to look up
those yeah but in general
if i draw you an arbitrary reaction do
you have a fighting chance of saying
what the energy
absorption or release is
well if we have the bond energies for
the bonds that are broken and created we
can approximate it using that old method
and again it would still be look up
individually for those who are trying to
or some set of rules that you would use
when they're certain bonds are combined
together in a molecule and bob and jason
so this is not an application i've tried
to do but i mean if you had a high level
electronic structure theory and you had
a unimolecular reaction
would it do you any good to to compute
the the total energy of both states or
is that not
um a good representation of uh the
reaction are you trying to do a delta h
of reaction at zero k and then we're
productive yes that yes that's what i
would say yeah you you you pick your
base set in theory level and do the
calculation of all the reactants all the
products and then
then go yeah that's actually
quite a good approximation
and what happens at finite temperature
so what do you mean by their corrections
or are there are there
yeah so if you go from 0k then then
there's uh you have to have the second
derivative so that you can do the
vibrational
corrections and then you do the thermal
corrections and you approximate the the
when you go from enthalpy to enthalpy
excuse me from when you go from
enthalpy to free energy
you have to approximate the entropy
usually use the ideal gas
approximation
and you also have to take into account
the symmetry number based on the
geometry too i think for the entropy yep
yeah the entropy term often gets left to
one degree or another depending on what
your needs are yeah
okay
boy so we might actually be able to do
chemistry it might just turn out to be
graph rewriting
well no except the electronic structure
calculations are not at that time well
that's the hard part we haven't got
something that does that right now
right
right
um
yeah okay
all right well so so what is the what
okay so we have questions about
representing these reactions
we have partial answers to that
you know i don't know whether the graph
rewriting is probably the actual
algorithmic graph rewriting for anything
that is realistically chemically
interesting
there is not a big algorithm problem
there
is that true i mean we're not dealing
with big
we're not dealing with complicated graph
rewriting questions
right i mean so essentially
so i mean
i don't know if this is what you mean
but i mean what what we do at the moment
is
we do the subgraph matching and then we
enumerate the matches
and then we do the stitching together um
to create the
the products um i mean so the
substructure replacement and keeping
track of the atom mapping
right i mean i'm just wondering because
we have pretty good technology if you're
doing graph rewriting i don't know
whether we have to wheel it in for this
case
well what would be a complicated graph
rewriting problem
uh hypograph of the million nodes
being rewritten with um you know finding
these particular
uh subgraphs in it i mean generally
subgraph identification is an mp
complete problem
and it is often hard for chemistry but
um nowhere near like what you're facing
with a million node hypergraph
right but where every node is the same
whereas what you have is a bunch of i
mean you might have a bunch of carbon
atoms but they're not you're going to
have a bunch of
local structure which allows you to
dramatically prune the possible matches
well interesting okay anything else we
need to make sure to cover right now
that's all i had oh there was a comment
a question on our live stream
from fender
can these quest reactions be run at
different temperatures and pressures
answer not yet
asking for a friend who wants to make a
super hard diamond in the
jupiter atmosphere return to earth
boy
really why would it be a super hard
diamond isn't a diamond a diamond
i thought it was just a carbon atom
there's not there's new pentadiamonds
well there are different carbon isotopes
and that electrodes
heliotropes i mean yeah um
i thought like graphite and diamond but
yes but you're saying but but um michael
is saying there's a a penta diamond what
is it penda diamond that's i think the
new super material oh really conjectured
i believe it's congestion
the only computer so far it's only
computed
what what you have to you have to worry
be careful about these new allotropes
right i once would write a kurt vonnegut
book right where the new alexa
right is nine
i put in the chat
yeah
was claudio looking at that michael last
summer also i do not know
i think he's the one that tipped me off
to that
well that's a hypothetical crystal
structure i understand but so what it's
a
useful crystal structure we're not
anything we're making in a computer is
also hypothetical i mean it's a
yeah
yeah but what is it in fact um
it's just a a different carbon cage
structure than the diamond but with
different hybridization of these carbon
atoms somehow
diamond is just tetrahedral carbon right
i mean
yes and i believe these are also
i'll take up the stuff from last summer
and send it to you stephen okay i know
the paper has been retracted so
thank you for watching that's all
interesting
that's strange okay because because
likely because the energetics don't work
out like you can't oh i did i didn't
photography
but doesn't this remind you of christine
don't get me started on that i spent a
whole bunch of christmas vacation trying
to come up with that allotrope
and i still have the driving models all
tangled up on my desk
okay
wait wait you mean physical models
yeah
i'm an old-fashioned chemist
you mean you actually have like like
like one of these plastic chemistry
constructions that things
well i i had those i've got metal ones
that it's called a driving
molecular modeling kit
i'm the one that has the plastic ones
jason has the plastic ones there are
pictures of them in this blog or this uh
presentation jason gave last year oh
okay
interesting interesting well
um
uh
great okay well i think it's probably
enough for
this yeah marco and uh live streams
commenting be nice to have crystal
computation to orphan language we have a
bunch of stuff coming on that right
isn't is claudio still working on that
no he has he and i have not worked on it
in
close to a year
didn't it did did it get to a point
where it could be put in the function
repository or not
it's it's close
there is also currently a really nice
pack i mean so so the the package that
bob and claudio were working on is great
but there is also uh uh
one put out in the community called max
rd or ma with capital x
rd
uh uh um targeted towards
crystallographers that i really oh well
okay
cool
well it is something
we eventually should have in the system
yeah there's absolutely just all stuff
all right
well good very nice lovely really
set for version 13
i think so yep onward onward to
reactions yep after that okay thanks